I should be Rookie of the Year because I
should be a rookie of the year because
there's this narrative around Jimmy that
he is like some bad teammate those
people just don't know much about
basketball what their hero this time the
hero from the University of Kentucky
rookie for the Miami Heat
and we're taking it there in Miami
what's a the Rose checking in from Miami
with the rook with Taylor rooks how wild
is it that you live in Miami yeah that
is why I love it though look at this
that's crazy though is even it's like
being around you you fit Miami
everybody says that that doesn't make
sense how do you fit Miami it because
you have the chill like lay back
I know you can't swim good I know you
can't still have it so that's for you
know you don't but you know just until
you take your swimming lessons I do
that's for you
how did it end up that you can't swim I
used to take swimming lessons but I
never would go I'm a great swimmer are
you but only if you want you know not
messing up my hair
it's insane because you just turned 20
okay you just got out of your teens okay
I'm not trying to sign you or anything
yeah you're grown 20 I feel you but
you're 20 years old and like this is
what you do like this is your life
living in Miami being in the NBA you
ever feel like life moved really quickly
I think going to Kentucky made it how
fast it did that's what I like Coach Cal
sets his players up for success with the
one year program getting out and going
one and done yeah I know if I did my
what I was supposed to Kentucky that it
was
you know what I was doing when I was 20
I was like a little apartment in
Champaign Illinois in college
Ian ramen noodles look at you now yeah
but like at 20 I can't imagine all the
things like available to you everybody
has their own path
yeah different different ways of getting
where they wanted to go yeah have it's
quicker okay complete this sentence
I should be Rookie of the Year because I
should be a Rookie of the Year because
look at my numbers I've missed a couple
games but I feel like I've impacted the
game a lot and I'm also the youngest guy
and that's conversation all right so
with the heat this year you're in a
locker room that has Jimmy Butler you
got Jam buckets got another talented
player in Kendrick none what are the
dynamics like we all bring like our own
personality to locker room and then we
all bring our own skillset to the court
so we all fit in jail well together I
couldn't ask for a better lock
what personality does Jimmy bring
Jimmy's like the leader the head of the
snake at the same time he's like funny
like he cried jokes he's funny he's
hysterical what personality does Bamberg
vams like the laid-back leader who is
this like
a vet but he's still young so I was like
defines the difference between the two
well personality does Kendrick bring
that rookie who doesn't talk much I only
hear him talking when we hang out away
from the court it seems like you and
Jimmy have become like super close how
has that relationship blossomed it
started in summer when I went to Chicago
to work out with him and then he had his
house all the time for like we just hang
out you know it's weird because you know
Jimmy has been on my show I like Jimmy a
lot there's this narrative around Jimmy
that he is like some fat teammate what
would you say to people and they
believed that to be true I think what
we've done so far just alone this year
and what he's done he should have been
there I think all-star starter those
people just don't know much about
basketball like he he just hates to lose
who loves
where him and some players on his
previous teams there was a gap in their
[Music]
checking in always some Dolphins right
here yo oh oh
what's the dolphin noise I was watching
that interview with you Jimmy and bam
and when they were talking about players
that you were like every player they
name was white and you're like okay you
can't just compare me to all the white
players yeah but one thing that's
interesting about you is I don't think
you're viewed in the NBA is like the
token white guy yeah you're just a part
of the team yeah but I think for most
players it's hard to kind of overcome
that label yeah I agree I think that's
why I who I am I say you just got it
like as a little kid I was taught to
just be different if I wanted to get to
the NBA
to my dreams I had to be different your
Twitter name is RAF underscore Tyler
what
what does RAF stand for enlighten
it stands for rich and famous okay well
I did I did that before I got to the NBA
so you were rigid fine miss before you
got to the NBA yeah my she's good so
you've always had this persona about you
the type of persona that would say
they're rich and famous in the sixth
grade I guess how would you describe
your personality
I'm Matt persona my personality I would
say I'm confident okay I'm very
confident about going on every single
person in BA that I would ask about you
they all use the same word which was
swaggy where does this lad come from
well I developed it on my own I guess
yeah over time got my swag together I
guess and then today you were trying to
be like me with the shoes yeah you were
trying to be like no you provided that
the swag you seen all my Instagram page
you want to be like me that's crazy
you know I rap too no Robert you got
music yeah me ain't Cana you really have
a mixtape yeah yeah this our songs right
here we got this one
this one we got this one
white okay Miami we ride on a yacht
these diamonds they dancing that cost me
a lot the pegs in town I sweat like a
month christen to your object to my
socks you have a low flow to you all
right Tyler that is enough yacht for me
let's give him the car and take you home
okay so before we go I had a friend of
mine make a video for you I think you
might like yo Taylor what up T
man just say from former Bobby he
playing man just want to say how proud I
am of you and how you represent yourself
killer so man keep doing what you do you
know how to play this game of basketball
you know keep making us proud man
especially the way you swag when you
walk into that arena keep doing it
brother all right look that's dope
do you a let's do what's it like hearing
that he's a legend of Miami so it's
hearing that from him you were genuinely
surprised I didn't think I'll be him at
all okay so just kind of hop GP Dwyane
Wade has to be in there but give me your
top five Miami Heat player D wave Chris
Bosh
check okay I like that
why chocolate yeah now I got a asking
your top five Kentucky Wildcats oh can I
say myself you can't you must say you're
sorry
so me John Wall Anthony Davis D book
first chef okay
strong lift I do that's my dad said now
allegedly you are this like swaggy guy
who can dress well so I will show you
some photos of your fellow rookies and
their outfits and you're gonna grade
them for me okay like a B C D F alright
okay
first Scion that's yeah he didn't really
pop out yeah Thank You with that leper
pleaser
that's a seat he should've did leather
pants to you would have got full
leopards yeah okay
Darius I'll forgive him really how many
people would wear that the confidence of
situation and he walked in there real
confident - I remember watching the
tunnel walk away yeah yeah okay so my
one takeaway from spending this update
with you is I hope you realize how lucky
you are
yes you really I thank you so much I
appreciate you having me yeah it was a
great time great great day off day on
the boat I appreciate it yeah have a
great season
thank you hey I see you too
you
what's up everybody this is Taylor rooks
thank you for watching my show be sure
to subscribe to Bleacher Report's
youtube channel for other videos clips
and highlights